yeah anyway I think when I was presented
with the offer I didn't initially what I
wasn't that keen on it mainly because I
I didn't really know anything i I you
know when something like hey you want to
come here
yes country it's like okay I mean
Japan's cool but I need from the oh yeah
yeah II don't know anything yeah I think
over time I just especially when I found
out that you were gonna go 100% I think
that was like all right well at least I
have you know my boys here so if I do
get lonely oh good
but I mean yeah meeting friends wasn't a
problem anyway but I think it is scary
it is yeah I think that's it I'll go
into later with like what I think is
important yeah move here and then just
got to the point where I'd nothing
better going on and people gave me so
much [ __ ] for saying that my video by
the way I got really yeah I literally
sat in my video I said I said nothing
better going on that's why I moved here
and people think that like I'm being
like nonchalant or joking like I I
didn't like yeah when you're not you but
you don't have anything to do other than
YouTube and hang out with your friends
to do whatever you need to do to be
happy but I literally had nothing better
going on so I'm like in my head there's
no reason why I wouldn't take this cuz
it gives me a purpose to you know just
better myself as a person I get to learn
new things get to meet new people reason
why I moved is walls because like in
Australia like you know how you do it
right it's like you know I had like
great friends you know from uni and high
school who I would hang out with every
now and yeah and like you know I had
places to go to yeah but it wasn't
exciting anymore
me like it was just routine yeah like
her I hate getting into routine with
anything right so I was like yeah I mean
you know I haven't like yes I've spent
half my life here technically but I
haven't really like gone out to like
fully school the country yeah four years
later I've no any close to exploring
this place yeah like there's so many
more places I want to go to still
haven't left Tokyo that road trip that
we plan alright once once the rotor is
gone it's out of love Tokyo ones yeah